do except I argue except it's like I
usually marketing with people
are we arguing about who's the best
sibling which is clearly me me
[Laughter]
oh that's Jazz so and then what so then
another question from the chat is what
advice do you have from someone that
wants a big family and wants to raise a
lot of kids I love this one can I oh
sure
um again it's like just do it and most
people they have kids and they stop
living and I watch I watch person after
Mom after Mom after Mom and they just
stop they stop living they stop going
and you know when you know Adam was
three weeks old I think when we took him
on a nine country trip in Europe and you
know he got his passport on the first
like on the way home from the hospital
and we just did it and and people are
like well this might happen that it
might but it might not and so you know
having a lot of kids doesn't cost like
the same amount of money exponentially
and I remember when you guys were little
and we would spend you know we get our
credit card bill at the end of every
month and it was a certain amount of
money and then as we had more kids it
didn't really change because you stopped
going out to eat you start you know
handed clothes down you can afford to do
a lot more and the value and just the
joy that was in your four walls you
didn't have to go pay for it outside
those four walls and so yeah is it hard
there's a lot of hard days but you know
when I'm 51 years 51 I always say I'm
52. who rounds up I don't know
um you know I'm 51 years old some of the
best gifts my parents ever gave me
wasn't you know wasn't an education or
anything else it was my siblings and so
you know I hope that when you look at
your life and you're 51 years old I hope
you feel the same way that it wasn't the
trips or the car or the you know
whatever it was you know you're the
people you're surrounded by
what do you think Dad I'm sorry um tips
for raising a lot of kid and having a
big family oh I don't know don't don't
don't take too much shot of it don't I
can decide to don't think everything is
a crisis dying the walls are falling and
just sit down and hey that's like notice
guys most times I don't I sometimes I
react don't get me wrong but for the
most part I just like okay what's going
on now who's yelling at who who's it now
so I mean you guys and I spend a lot of
my life you guys may not think that but
being like a peacemaker I do my best
maybe too much because Eva pushes it a
little too far what do I do
that's the point you answered my
question already
um what do you do okay but the point is
you just gotta not not everything is not
a crisis life is just it's just a sit
back figure it out get through it go to
the next point and so it just didn't
enjoy it try to enjoy it I mean don't be
in like a hot studio in the middle of
it's like yeah we're all melting yeah
yeah London doesn't have a see I don't
know what you guys are doing out here
it's the hottest day of the year and
like how long
like forever
being organized helped too if you have
your health there's nothing else I'm
watching my my siblings like to start
dropping because the health you must
have your health and so if you have that
if you don't lose a limb lose a foot
lose a leg you can always get through it
you can't start again you can always do
something it's Health that's the problem
I mean it just is I mean I'm watching it
so seriously now I watch my sister my
brother my other sister I mean I think
it's four or five now they're just it's
just it's sad
and there's and that's the one thing you
must maintain and if you do that
everything else doesn't matter you go
live on a beach then somewhere if you
have to but but if you don't have that
and you've paid a lot of time and then
the life sucks I just watch it no that's
the one thing I always say about you and
I'm like telling people stories I'm like
my dad can stay calm in anything and
like whenever I'm freaking out about
something you're so good at like
bringing me down to earth I mean like
it's not that big of a deal calm down
you're not dying your house is on fire
but don't worry about it even like when
I was here I lost everything I lost like
everything on a train like my ID my
wallet like literally everything and I'm
like crying and he's and you were just
like you're fine just order new ones
what are you gonna do I'm like Dad I'm
locked out of my apartment
Adam lost his laptop the other day
yesterday got stolen and then a day it
sucks but it is what it is because I
blame Dad for that I wouldn't have taken
it out of my bag but yeah it was my
fault I forgot it on top of the car yeah
actually actually be honest Chaz
actually recommended you taking another
car back but that's okay but the point
is that's the point it's not that
important plus there's an old piece of
[ __ ]
it was a horrible laptop so it's it's
gonna help you more because you get a
new one crack screen weight yeah it's
horrible didn't really run that well so
for that reason why'd they steal it
because they're stupid
[Music]
it was sitting on top it gets worse this
is the worst part of the whole It's the
funniest part is yeah he first lost his
wallet okay so first is no no passport
oh no no this is why but well so we we
have this about a long trip yeah
that's like the same five minutes but
the point was yeah so we're looking
through with this whole car we tore it
apart looked everywhere in this car I'm
telling you there's nowhere else we
couldn't look and so finally we actually
give up and then Adam downloads this app
called I have a tile in my wallet yeah
it's a towel which is unbelievable like
I think no way that's not gonna work
you're full no way in hell so we're
walking around this car with this tile
and it kept saying stronger stronger
weaker weaker stronger stronger
we couldn't find it like it was like the
nuttiest thing in the world and guess
what it has the driver's door has this
real long pocket and I'll be damned the
wall was always back in that pocket I
was like shocked that damn the thing
worked and I checked there I just want
to make this clear I stuck my hand back
there and the wall yeah the wallet was
lodged up somehow I'd gotten stuck up so
when I reached my hand back there I
reached and felt nothing so then I
assumed there's nothing in there somehow
I got lodged up in the into the door and
it just was there yeah and so then we
spent like 20 minutes searching for this
wallet and then we we finally find it so
I just grab all my stuff apparently not
my laptop too but and then we start
walking away we walk all the way inside
and we're about to go through security
and I go hey Dad I think I forgot my
laptop we go back and I search strip
search both cars completely down no
laptop and so yeah it was gone yeah and
we think we left it on top of the car so
whoever's walking by is it it was like
late at night three some people like
only those very people who are taking it
yeah but whatever whatever it's going to
help in the end just it's just kind of
funny how the whole thing works out well
it's like a mindset because you can see
the good in anything yeah because he's
gonna do a laptop yeah I think it's like
just don't make everything into a crisis
like it just doesn't need to be you know
there's uh Gabrielle fell while hiking
the other day Adam was chasing me
he was chasing me and red car
um was trying to defeat blue car but
blue car still won
but she's got stitches and you know and
but first of all she finished the hike
you know we didn't just turn back we
finished it you said I could though yeah
but but it was a mindset right yeah it
was it didn't whether she got stitches
or had a hole in her knee as long as she
was wanting to keep doing it why
wouldn't you keep going but I would say
if he knew the energy if we knew the
extent of the energy
injury thought we should take you down
carrying it but we didn't and you know
and then we kept going we just went to
the ER we got it stitched up and you
know we went to
went to the next place so the whole
point is it's just a mindset to just
keep going just keep going did you do
you guys feel like there's problems that
come with success
like there's problems walking across the
street when it comes to like jealousy
and that sort of thing I don't know